okay let's destroy this person
proud Gotham sub
I I saw this name and I got slightly
triggered except it's completely okay to
be a proud Gotham sub
I'm also a product Gotham sub
okay stop for Gambit time ooh uh traxxer
time
no just Italian time
Italian
oh
oh
okay
I have to convert my opponent into a
proud Rosen sub
hey welcome to Jules Gambit
you're just in time to witness such a
nice meet
do I exert my dominance
okay I'll do one more
I think it's it's totally possible to be
both a proud Gotham and proud Rosen sub
it's not mutually exclusive
do I play Levy's opening let's play one
of Levy's openings Joe Bravo London oh
okay
England gather time
interesting
we're gonna have the queen sack line
no mercy
that was probably a mouse that I wasn't
meant to play Queen take C3
9-1-1 what's your emergency oh yeah that
was from earlier when I said someone
call an ambulance
I forget what the emergency was but
maybe it is needed for my opponent
after Queen Z2
do I do I try and adopt the proud Gotham
sub
okay I'll try and adopt the proud Gotham
sub
to put them in their place
I mean how many moves total have I
played under 30 right
uh let's play osullivan or let's take a
free Pawn
play this
okay moving a little bit slowly this
game
uh oh
oh no my Pawn
yeah Queen takes the queen would get
trapped
I have 15 seconds left
oh no my time
okay now I'm up on time
foreign
I think I missed E5 earlier
[Music]
I create mating time
don't mess with my gun
[Music]
that's not quite meet
okay
okay to adopt the proud Gotham Sun I
need to win seven more
uh if england gamut I'll play a Danish
okay let's play Joe Bravo London
oh
this is the best case scenario in
jumbova London
Knight B5 and
it's already winning for whites
that's a funny opening trap
oh no blocks Queen
so both games is white I wanted eight
moves
oh okay that's four games let's play
England
positional chest
yeah more solid approach here
the sneaky plan is to create the battery
and then try and check me on each two
and maybe sock some stuff
and G3 is such a sackable square
do I even Rook lift bro
hmm
that's not even the sack because I win
back material
that's a good move
okay A fitting ending with a fork
come on I'm not getting reading for this
oh no okay I'm putting my reading at
risk
okay oh he's playing Carol Khan okay
I'll play um the opening that crushes
the Carroll Khan
oh no my queen
oh opponent actually knows what they're
doing
this is the first game as white I'm not
winning in eight moves
unfortunately
I've trapped my own Bishop
don't think black wants to take it
though
oh no my Bishop
oh yes my position
[Music]
oh triple Fork
more Forks
okay
four more games
let's see if I can manage
I should have played The Budapest
now we just have a normal opening
opponent's been playing a lot of Levy
openings like hero Khan
's Gambit is definitely a levy opening
uh-oh
um
yeah that was a bad decision on my part
this is the first game I'm like kind of
uncomfortable
good opening from lights never mind
actually the opening was good this
middle game move slightly questionable
okay maybe I'll maybe I'll play like a
Mainline Queen's Pawn never mind
though no need Gambit accepted
no mercy here a lot of moves come with
Initiative for white
uh let's play this move
um
B4 is nice
I was expecting Queen A5 Chuck
ah this is too nice
oh no my queen
okay I've only had Knight F3 check
I could have like been losing there
[Music]
there goes all of locks Brooks
okay two more games
okay well crazy opening can I play I
want to play a Stafford
I need to stop her to
um oh Sullivan let's play O'Sullivan
or the reverse orangutan
wow
on the funny position let's take that
attack in the night
so we have like a reverse French Karo
Khan type thing
okay I'm gonna go and set up the Greek
gift
H5 and Bishop H2
I don't care that the center is
crumbling
wow
this looks nice
23
interesting
gotta move faster
and down a piece
up on time
okay final game
uh what opening do I play
let's play a hillbilly against Carol
Khan
assuming C6 is played
ooh
now F3 is not a great move
but we have a kind of black and Redeemer
type position
uh oh actually it's fine
Bishop was defended f7's attacked
no mercy here
no mercy
night school's just gonna Chill on f8
uh and maybe get trapped wow Knight's
trapped
[Music]
active King
good try
okay
that's 10 games
thank you Alice chess
okay that's what you get for being a
proud Gotham sub